each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
my pleasure to introduce Brian Chen from
UCLA brian is graduated or graduated I
graduated graduate Lee congratulations
it was what a pod milstein students into
UCLA and he's going to talk to us about
his dissertation work on improving the
development of interactive software
through new languages and patterns hi so
today I want to talk to you about my
work on exactly what Jim just mentioned
so before we get further I just want to
quickly say what interactive software
actually is or what I'm using that term
form so interactive software is software
which the raddest execution takes in
input and produces output as opposed to
sort of the more classic non-interactive
style of software which takes all of its
input at the beginning of a program at
that program initialization and that
produces output by program termination
so interactive software is a very large
and important segment of software
including stuff like web applications
and servers user interface software
varying kinds and even going so far as
to say video games so for the purposes
of this talk I'm going to give you a
quick example of interactive software
we're going to be using throughout the
rest of the talk which is a simple
guessing game so here we have two
entities a player in a game and they're
going to interact with each other in
order to sort of play this guessing game
at the very beginning the game is idle
me that there's actually you know no at
game going on so the first thing the
player has to do is to start the game
when it does this the game will actually
pick the correct answer for this
execution and then the gate was ready to
begin at this point the player can
attempt to guess that answer so first
off you try is 30 that is not the
correct answer so though game replies
too high then the gate player guesses 15
which is equipped course too low and
then finally he guesses 22 which is the
correct answer
which is correct so the game says so but
at the same time that ends the game
because the game is complete they
guessed correctly so now in order to
continue the game the player must now
start the game again and it has to pick
a new answer to be able to proceed so
this is the pseudocode who can use a
describe this particular behavior of
this game we can see here we have the
outer loop looping over various rounds
of this game once the player actually
starts the game then it picks a random
random answer and it goes through a loop
to get the guests from the player check
what the result is and then once the
players guess correctly exit that loop
so this code works great except for one
thing which is the fact that the the red
functions here actually block one call
that is when you call them they would
they wait until these responded in order
to return so blocking tends to be a
problem in these systems so this code
requires blocking and of course when
you're actually blocking no other work
can can be happened in the rest of the
system of course for a game like this
it's relatively easy but if you assume
we start adding in more components such
as a unit interface user interface this
game having other sort of side
operations have to be run this can be a
great problem so the standard one
standard solution for this problem is
the event driven model of software where
we have a component built for the
guessing game which accepts in events
from some external entity and then
whenever it receives an event it will
then execute a handler to hand to return
some result of that event back to the
person who call who sent to the event
and then of course possibly change its
internal state in order to represent the
changes that event caused so with that
understanding we can see here a very
simple picture of the sort of event
driven model of this be guessing game
state machine we have two states here
one where's idle when where it's running
in the idle state the player can say
start in order to actually start the
game and in the running state the player
can guess and depending on whether that
guess is correct or incorrect it'll
either go
loop around back into the running state
or go back to the idle state so a common
way of implementing this event driven
style and object-oriented languages is
the state design pattern so but mostly
probably familiar with this but I'll
just cover it very quickly we have what
I'll call the state machine object this
guessing game which maintains a
reference to an object of type game
state now game state there is an
interface that interface has two methods
on it one one method for each the two
events this game will accept that is the
start start method and the guest method
and there are multiple classes this game
idle and game running state one for each
of the two states that we have which
implement the actual operations of this
thing so during the execution of the
guessing game curr state will point to
an instance of either game idle and game
running and the appropriate method
bodies of those of the appropriate
implementations of these states will
handle the operations that we discussed
earlier earlier so the state design
pattern has a number of advantages so
first off the sort of classic version of
the event driven model requires us to
dispatch off of both the current stated
component is in and the events which are
sent to it often in that case it
requires manual dispatch of either one
one of the two or possibly both so
dynamic in the state design pattern
dynamic dispatch gives you that for free
that is what object is being pointed to
by the guessing game tells you which
state odd which state you're in and what
operations a call from and which method
you call determines which uh which
actual event handler to take care of to
run at that time furthermore the state
design pattern uses static typing in
order to enforce the correctness of the
state machine definitions and usages
specifically by defining this interface
you know that every single state that
implements that interface has
implemented all the possible interfaces
that that state machine can accept it's
all taneously you know that whoever is
using the state machine will only call a
message which is actually valid on that
state machine so this is great at the
same time the state design pattern has
disadvantages the key one here being the
fact that it takes our nice pseudo code
which looks like this
into code that looks something like this
this code is certainly longer than a
previous one and I would argue that it's
harder to read write and maintain
overall then the pseudocode version was
um so for this particular talk we'll be
focusing on 33 particular problems of
the state design of the vengers and
model overall the state design state
design pattern in particular which are
the inversion of control lack of
modularity and asymmetric control now
I'll describe what these three problems
are as we proceed through the talk now
the last thing I point I want to make is
that each of our solutions for these
problems all target modern level high
the modern high level object-oriented
languages making either minor
modifications to them or working
entirely within them in order to
actually solve these problems and so
okay so here's an outline of the talk
roughly we have talked about each of the
three problems and our solutions about
an hour solutions for them I'll briefly
mention some of the related work of this
of this medicine of my future work and
then finally conclude so first off let's
talk briefly about inversion of control
so here we have a tiny snippet of the
pseudo code that we saw earlier I and of
course we have this you know big glaring
red get guess blocking function in the
middle here so as we said before we
can't in order to be able to avoid
blocking we can't really have that so
how can we solve this in sort of the
event-driven style well you'd like to
sort of split up the code along the
lines of that you know blocking
functions you only can give us up
beforehand the stuff afterwards but
clearly here syntactically that won't
work we're breaking up this do-while
loop into two pieces so we said so it's
just not possible as we can see so the
ultra the alternative to this is to
instead implement these things as you
know these functions handlers here but
this creates some more problems first
off we're on the left hand side the
local context manages all of our state
for us that is we have you no answer
here is a local variable on the other
side we can see that we have to create
answer as an actual in stab as an
instance field of one of these one of
our state objects which we do have to do
more
ewell management of what these actual
values have in them in addition the fact
that we've more importantly perhaps we
have this loop on the left hand side
which is completely hidden by the code
on the right hand side there's a
practically an implicit do-while loop
there which is shown by the fact that
we're not changing the current state in
this guest function unless we get the
correct answer so instead of having
these explicit control structures as you
do on the Left we have to start how
these input is we implicitly manage our
control flow by signing to this curse
state field in the guessing game and
this makes it just much more much harder
to read to read and understand an
existing state machine and this is
partially leads us to have code that
looks like this so my approach was to
create a new control structure which
allow instead of requiring us to split
up our code like this allowed us to
pause and resume our code to allow us to
use normal control flow primitives as
you like that do while loop in general
in addition to doing this we provide
compatibility with this mechanism with
this control structure and mechanisms
around it with existing object oriented
models specifically the example that we
have here the responder J is my
implementation for the this control
structure and language feature in the
context of Java so this new control
structure is this thing called an event
loop so effectively this is responsible
for three different operations first off
when control reaches the beginning of an
event loop that allows that at that
point the executioner for that
interactive code is paused until the
next event comes in well the next event
comes in dispatch goes to the
appropriate case statement in here
either the named one for the for the if
you have the exact right kind of event
or the default if you don't have none of
the above apply and then execute the
code there in when code when execution
runs off the end of one of these case
blocks the actual execution loops back
at the beginning to the beginning of the
event loop to wait for the next event of
course you can use standard controls
control operations in Java such as
continuing
make an order to break out of this thing
so you don't you're not necessarily
locked in to this particular loop so
describe this in more detail I want to
show you our pseudocode written it as
for our our pseudocode for the guessing
game written inside of responder J so
you can see that this looks a lot more
like the pseudocode that we had earlier
and in order to sort of give you some
more examples I want to sort of step
through it one by one so when we first
initialize this interactive component
execution comes down it's the first
event loop and then pause it's waiting
for the next event so then where we get
our start the game event it goes to the
start game event here which of course
which dispatches there and then the code
proceeds Prix a new random answer and
then goes the next event loop at which
time it again pauses now of course we're
inside the game so now we just wait to
have the player I continually you know
guess for example 30 here if this is not
the right answer so it won't actually
break out of this loop and will return
back beginning the event loop and then
when eventually when he eventually does
get get the correct answer then we we
print that it's correct answer B guess
equals the answer is now you're able to
break out of the loop which takes us
back to the bottom of the start game k
statement here which of course will then
make us loop back the beginning of the
event loop here and the game repeats
just as what this man says we desired
before so we've expanded this particular
controller proach a control structure to
allow for you know of course methods you
know function and where method calls
within these things as well so you have
full generality of methods in there in
addition which is a good advantage when
we actually start talking about our
experience with this particular project
so for our experience we yes you know
their face either
you go back to the serial version where
you were getting getting the gas huh
there's some product or something that
that get guests be able to generate yeah
I don't see how that that is generated
here um you can certainly you can
certainly have coding here which is
implemented which is implemented to
print out that guess you can either do
it by just before you get to the event
loop here or at the end of one of these
blocks as is appropriate or of course
there's a lot of flexibility have with
the existing control structure cultural
cosas de Java to do this appropriately
um so yeah obviously need out right now
for the that get guess right now all it
is is simply just getting it from
getting formation yes so that I guess
the the second question that follows on
from that is so I have to guess that
lockbox and somebody presses texting a
guess and the presses okay okay what
does exactly does that do to cos the
event loop to know that you get the
guest case ah so what it is the part of
the story that I'm not telling you is
about how this interactive logic melds
with the rest of the object-oriented
world here all of this execution occurs
within the context of a single object
which I call a responder and thus the
name responder j the idea is that all of
these that these events here as we see
them appear as methods on that object so
when the dialog box will be run is an
external part of this thing and when the
sort of the main part of the program
says okay we have a guess it would then
go it would send the start sorry the
guest event to that object just as a
method call and so that method would
then run until hits the beginning the
next event loop and a meal control back
to the person who called that method
that method yes vision of America
instead of error if you just throw
accessible
currently we do not currently have a
particularly good exception model for
this kind of thing because of the sort
of complexities of what if you throw
like a static static exception here and
you know if you goes all way to the top
to youth and throw that again further
out so right now this is probably that
this error right now just prints out an
error message there are ways of return
also are ways returning information as
part of the process of these responders
so that will give you some way of
indicated there was an error in the
execution of something integrated here
is
um we in our current implementation know
we have some we have some ideas of how
we can do it but not at the moment okay
any other questions okay so let me skip
ahead for a moment here Shh here we are
ok so our experience in this case was in
the context of a library called the J
Dom XML parsing library which of course
parsed XML using a parse XML into the a
dom tree for instance and one of the
components of this thing I took created
a handler for the sex event-based XML
parsing library and use that particular
handler to create a dom tree out of it
so for those not familiar we have the
sax basically provides a set of
interfaces which indicate various events
that you can see as you're parsing an
XML document such as we see here we say
here's an event start element which we
see the open element in an XML file we
see another start element for a child we
add some text to that element and so on
and so forth and the idea for this
component is to take this the serial set
of events being called on this interface
and create the tree on the right that
you see so the original component I was
had a lot of inversion of control in it
as well showing that in the next slide
and our goal for this particular project
was to try to re-implement it using
responder j in order to prevent this
universe control from occurring in the
first place more importantly because of
this nice nested style XML there was
this natural recursion that was
occurring throughout this code which we
weren't able to actually access because
of this inverter because of the
inversion of control so to demonstrate
what app with us so to show you what
this code actually look like originally
here's a little brief snippet there's a
lot of manual dispatch on fields
internally to change we can change
between different behaviors in the code
such as you can see down here where we
dispatch off this at root variable to
have two different bodies execute and
Italy kept track of a lot of different
things including its current stack now
it may not seem like it in this
particular case but this is actually
keeping track of the stack
by reassigning the current element to
this element variable here in order to
pop off the stack o to get asked for
that the current elements parents to pop
back up so and over overall the flow of
this code became very complicated to
follow quite quickly so in order to when
we reimplemented it we're able to create
methods that look something like this so
here we have a single method build
element which effectively recursively
builds these elements so you're supposed
to call this immediately after getting a
start element event it creates a new
element and then performs an event loop
which repeatedly goes through and every
time he sees a start element will
recursively call itself to produce a new
element and add itself to this current
element when it's complete and of course
when we get an end element event we
return that our current element to our
to our caller and so this because lets
us use this natural recursion for the
for the sack saddam converter of the j
tom i guess o.o the respondent yes so
like i said i didn't mention some of the
external part the details of Zoar the
interface here but this is what defines
sort of stuff that happens on the intern
I'd be in the internal interactive code
weird stuff it happens as part of a
normal object any other questions ok so
our result was we successfully modified
sax dumped amber to do this sort of
thing Andrew cus took five different
responding methods in order to implement
this and of course naturally the logic
for the related code was now all very
localized so we can cease with
regression of you know each stir a step
in the algorithm to build these Dom
trees and in addition of course and let
us allow us to use standard control flow
structures in order to implement these
things alright so that is responder J
next we wanted to talk a little bit
about lack of accessibility so in
general in in general for non
interactive software extensibility is
very easy to obtain we see this all time
in altering languages where we use
inheritance in order to provide
extensibility where we can add new
operations modifies and modify existing
operations to existing the algorithms
contain
within classes and naturally would want
to be the same thing an interactive code
so going back to our previous picture of
the state design pattern we see here
that you want to extend behavior of game
running with this modified game running
class month budgets do the Berlin we
only want override it in a very small
way the problem is the way that we're
doing it right now such as in the start
method in game running whenever we
change our state we're explicitly
constructing the next object the the
next object in sort of the sequence here
so actually this would be in a game idle
I'm sorry so this means that we don't
actually we would have to override also
this start method in order to be able to
to actually put in this modified game
running into our code and of course once
we change that one we have to then
extend other things the point where
there's some point where we have to sort
of have some root thing to be able to
change which of course makes means that
we have served override everything we
don't get really any advantage out of
this in the first place so first
question is how would we want to
actually override states how could we
how could we order ID states in this
thing second set a more subtle problem
is we want to add new events to the
existing state machine so on the top
here we see the state design patterns we
saw before but let's say we want to add
this hint state this this hint operation
so we could certainly extend the
existing game state interface over there
and of course once we solve the first
problem we could add create extensions
of the game idle and game running states
create the hint idle and hint running
states but part of the problem here is
that the guessing game all the way up at
the top there are still referring to the
current that the current state is still
of type game state this means that we
would effectively have to well even if
we were able to override like this every
time that we do so we'd have to assign
make sure we assign one of these hint
idle or hint running states every time
we called the hint event we'd have to
make a cast this leaves us open for all
sorts of fundamental errors here like
what happens if we forget you know this
is a simple one but let's say we had a
bunch of different states here what
happens if we didn't override a
particular class and then we try to run
to execute this hint state on it we get
at least a classcastexception
which of course defeats a lot of the
purposes of the state design pattern
which is to prevent these kinds of
errors from actually occurring so my
approach to solve this problem was to
require new constraints on the existing
state design pattern to provide several
of these kinds of extensibility and
naturally we then call it the extensible
state machine the state machine pattern
this is a pattern compatible with
multiple languages but of course in this
in this toss all disseminated in Java
1.5 so how do we actually want to extend
existing existing classes well we
clearly want to do the things we
mentioned before we want to be able to
add an override States in order to
modify the behavior of existing state
machines you want to add new events so
that we can actually have new operations
in our extension state machines and we
also want to be able to insert
interactive logic into the middle of
existing operations do not require us to
completely override every single thing
that we've done within a particular
operation now unfortunately not only
have time to talk briefly about the
first two of these and we can talk
offline or something about the the third
one so extensive for adding an override
States we've already mentioned the
problem which is that we can't easily
change states because they're explicitly
constructed in the event handlers so our
simple idea is why don't we require
people to create factory methods within
the state design pattern in order to let
us do you give us one level of
abstraction away from justice direct
it's anton similar to the UML diagram
you see here at the bottom this way
whenever we want to change the states
that we use we can simply extend the
existing guessing game and then override
the appropriate factory method to change
which particular type is created so that
certainly solves pretty easily problem
one problem to excessively number two
adding new events is a little bit more
tricky to handle so our problem here is
that we can't add new events to the
existing state because we already have
locked down the type of the current
state in the the state machine itself so
our idea for this was to use generics to
vary the type of the state interface so
now instead of guessing games being the
sort of atomic object by its
we add in this this sort of this bound
game state the idea is that basically
the actual current state can be anything
he is a tight yeah that we take we have
a type variable for the current state
which we use to define the current state
inside of the guessing game but we also
bound that particular as that particular
thing to actually require to implement
the game state as you see here of course
now that we have these factories means
we can all burn explicitly create our
factories we don't know what the type T
is at compile time so we have to now
make our classes abstract and as well as
these factories so but this also makes
it this time is a fairly easy to extend
these state machines so here for example
we have our hint state which extends
game state that part's easy and now to
extend the guessing game the hint gate
all the hint game has to do is create a
new bound 40 whereas says hint state is
now the new bound 40 and past that and
past that type variable T along to the
guessing game and this type system lies
will all work out because all things
that are T that our hint states are
going to have to be game states as well
so once we've done this means that now
we know the current state is of the
right type so you can proceed to create
our new implementations of both the hint
idle and hint running states inside of
this extension to be able to be added
later now of course is one step that's
still missing here which is the step of
concretization so right now when we have
one of these state machines we can't
actually instantiate them because we
have all these abstract factories so in
order to actually instantiate one we
have to extend one more time from that
state machine lock down the type of that
of the state interface for the specular
state machine so for example we have
hint state here as being the type of
this state machine and fauna and then we
have to implement all of the factory
methods for this for the concrete
version of hint game now these these
factory methods are all meant to be very
trivial to do in the sense that all they
should do is basically create an object
of the
proprio type defined by the hint game
itself by the extension and so is mostly
just boilerplate code by itself yes
ideas so the lists like separate purpose
these are separate proposals right now
um so yeah these are like I'm trying to
address each problem serve on its own at
the moment if that wasn't clear so fair
enough so with these recovered we're now
going to talk briefly about our
experience so once again we use the J
dot XML parsing library as a basis for
this but we've used it from a different
tactic here so to expand on what sax
does in addition to providing interfaces
to take these events that you'll see as
you're passing a parsing an XML file it
actually separates the events the
different groups mainly we have served
this kind of concept of a simple
interface which it handles stuff like
opening and closing entities as we've
already seen and it has more complicated
stuff like handling DT DS entities and
other sort of parts of the XML standard
and the original version of this class
implemented a bunch of these interfaces
all at once implying that me that all
the implementation of all these
different pieces was all combined into
one large piece of code again suggesting
that it was harder to read what was
actually going on in there so our goal
here was you to use our extensible state
machine pattern in order to actually
separate out these each of these parts
from the others so we create one base
state machine which only implemented the
simple set of events on the sax
interface and then we extended that to
add in the more complicated events
afterwards so the result is that we
actually did do this we the base state
machine ended up with eight different
states with 11 different event types
North extension added four new states
with the 12 new event types required by
these interfaces the code overall was
indeed more understandable once we
separate these into these different
conceptual parts unfortunately did
require us to create a net increase in
the number of lines of code so we had
two hundred forty lines for the base
state machine and 330 for the extension
versus the four-and-twenty form the
original
but we believe that the other advantages
of this provides the further
extensibility the readability and so on
outweigh the increase that we saw yes we
did not use the event loop construct
anyway ah the there is some overlap the
first one responder J required us to
actually create a language extension in
order to actually have it work this
thing is a general pattern and such as
available to anyone who actually just
has java you know is using java so
there's some overlap and functionality
between the two but you know we're short
according to the other direction which
is a little bit more code can we get you
have a lot some of the same advantages
so accessibility those the main
concentration any other questions ok I'm
fine oh the final point here is the fact
that so like I said before as you've
seen with the adding new events we had a
bunch of boilerplate that we had to
insert here so one way we can probably
mitigate the cervix tension of CODIS you
have tools to help us reduce this code
either by generating it for us or by
distorting maintaining in the background
without having you know for us to
actually be aware of what's going on so
let's see so this is the main part for
the sensible state machine pattern so
our final problem that I wanted to talk
about is this problem asymmetric control
so here we for both of the previous
projects that we've seen as well as the
event driven model on its own we have
this model where we have our state
machine which is being sent events by
some external component now I say that
that external component is a controller
because it's sending events to the state
machine and as such controlling its
internal execution by doing so so we
call of course the state machine itself
control e as well but this model isn't
always the case so take for instance
this little snippet of program which is
a a program designed to run our guessing
game as opposed to just a player sitting
out there running this thing on on their
own so this does a standard thing where
it makes a guess by figuring out what
the band on the guess is guessing the
thing in the middle so on and so forth
ah but notice afterwards we have the
switch statement we've modified guests
are instead of printing out whether it's
too low to high or correct it returns to
higher
lower correct um we have the switch
statement which dispatch between
different bodies of code depending on
what the actual execution happens so we
have to modify what our bounds are
depending whether it was too low or too
high if it's correct we even have to
change our control flow itself not just
a simple switch thing we had to break
out of this execution to wait for the
next game to start so this kind of model
itself has this very kind of manual
event event dispatch sir built into it
as well which means that we basically
have this code being controlled for a
moment when we call this guess event so
this means that our picture of having a
controller sending a bunch of events to
the control lee gets kind of flipped
around on its side so my argument is
that there are many natural interactive
components which have this exchange of
control throughout their lifetimes and
with the existing state design pattern
we have we're forced to do this kind of
unchecked manual dispatch which as we
mentioned before has many of the
problems of not be able to ensure that
someone handles all the valid cases and
not being able to and not be able to
check that make sure they're actually
sending only valid events to that entity
so we need to find some way of avoiding
this problem for these more complicated
interactive protocols and so my approach
is to we take we find a way to model the
message is flowing not just in one
direction but in both directions over
this products and then within Java we
use a continuation passing style between
these components in order for that on
the swap control between each other
between each other as it goes on
furthermore we leverage the static type
system of whatever language we're
implementing this in in order to ensure
that this model is followed correctly so
we call this the dialogue pattern which
is once again not a language extension
but just a but just a pattern which can
be followed as a general in any sort of
high-level operated language we
specifically demonstrated again in Java
1.5 so this might be familiar to some of
you but the sense of an interactive
protocol this idea where we take a look
at events passing back and forth in both
directions so for example our guess is
here are there are events in one
direction but too high
too low and correct are also vents
coming the other direction and we have
this particular transcript of what's
going on here of how these things flow
and we want to be able to have some way
of saying how what order are these
things supposed to occur in so our way
of describing interactive protocols tree
creates sort of models that look like
this now this is the model for our
guessing game now we can see a little
bit of similarity already to our exists
the state machine that we saw earlier
for this but in order to explain some
the details I should probably just show
you an example so here we have which we
start in the idle state like we always
do and now the player sends start the
game so we follow the star to edge to
the running state then we proceed to the
blues music guess which takes us to the
handle response state and notice that
both of these events were from the
perspective or sent from the perspective
of the player which means that both of
those times the player was in control we
indicate this in these diagrams via this
sort of gray node here now we wear a
white note handle response which
naturally would imply that's now the
game's turn to respond to this and so it
does with too high then we sort of
follow the rest of this protocol we you
know guess 15 which is this time too low
and finally we guess 22 which as you
recall is the correct answer and so we
follow the correct edge back to the idle
state v so mainly the thing to notice
here is it before when we strode the
state machine we had this kind of
ambiguity about which way we would go
when we hit this guess event now because
we have this other state this handle
response we can now be we can now follow
this protocol and make sure that we're
completely unambiguous about what of
what state we're going to enter into
after this next event is sent so now
these these images these sorry this
diagram here is not actually our pattern
this is just the way of sort of showing
how it works our pattern itself the way
we just find these interactive protocols
is entirely within Java code for
instance in this case we do it we have
our these little examples of interfaces
for this particular model here so every
single state in one of these protocol
diagram the one of these protocols
has an equivalent interface to them and
each interface provides a method for
each operation coming off of that state
so for example you see here we have
running and it has the guest method for
the guest edge coming off of it it can
of course take other arguments such as
the inch which guess has to accept in
order for to actually make a guess but
in addition has this other this other
argument called the state argument which
the first one to guess here which has
the type of the interface of the target
of that edge this provide and we'll
explain what this means in a moment but
one thing I want to draw your attention
to right now is the fact that notice
here that we have these interfaces and
these interfaces actually don't only
implement those sorry these these things
implement only those events which have
to be implemented in that particular
state before we had both the start and a
guess event for every state now we only
have this guess event this provides us
with this means that we don't have to
actually worry about stuff like air
conditions for particular events that we
don't really make sense in the context
as long as we follow this protocol will
be able to ensure that your only be
hauling valid message as we go along so
to show you more to show you how this I
have to work at implementation i want to
show you an example of how this would
execute in an actual machine so in this
case we have this idea of the player and
the game site as interaction so the game
this protocol overalls in the running
state so the game side has a running
object in it and of course this running
object implements this interface i
mentioned before so when someone someone
from the player side once send an
adventure to the running object it calls
the guest method on that object but
addition to passing along its guess it
passes along a reference to a handle
response object which is going to be in
the tin uation passing style accepting
is going to be as being passed along to
accept the response from the running
object as the next step of this protocol
notice here that this is why we have
this type on our this first argument and
the special type on this the guest
method itself this means that since we
have a hen response object it has to be
handled response audit that we send it
in order to be able to continue on
correctly now when we want the next step
is for example return to hi so the
running object sends calls the two high
method on that same hemel response
object which we can once again see we're
using the correct types of the reference
and so on and so this this continues ten
response object again sends running
Odrick the previous next object the
guest method again and passing itself as
sort of the next object and finally the
running out returns since 22 is the
correct answer we it returns the correct
it sends the correct event to the handle
response object but since it itself is
not an idle object it has created a new
Idol object in order to be able to
implement this so it with the in this
way we actually leverage the types in
order to do all these things knows that
everything we've done here is completely
type safe and that's how we're actually
using the type system to check these
protocols so the dialogue pattern
overall has a number of strong
advantages it provides this form of
symmetry making exchanges of controlled
easy between the different sides it
allows these different components to be
implemented independently all one has to
know is the the protocol interface
itself to implement either one side or
the other violations of protocols are
found statically by type errors and
finally it allows each state to only
implement pertinent events for its
current for what it needs to deal with
next now the dialogue pattern also has a
number of other features one of which is
the idea of sub protocols which sub
protocols are the protocols as a whole
as subroutines are two I guess you could
say routines as a whole in the sense
that we can use that there fragments of
interactive logic which we can
instantiate in multiple places within a
protocol um and we can use this for true
interactive code reuse as a part of it
so in addition this we provide several
completely optional tools again this
thing doesn't require any tools to
operate by itself but some days are
convenient so one of them is the ability
to have a visualizer to be able to take
these this interface definition of a
protocol definition and create these
diagrams out of it so you can just
easily see what add you know what does
your protocol actually do if your first
time you're actually looking at these
things second we have a way of creating
a proxy between different sizes we have
this idea of independent implementation
we can sort of put another layer in
between which routes the messages
appropriately between the two sides to
allow you to run I you to run these
interactive protocols or tweeting things
at different processing
potentially different computers on a
network if you so chose so limit oh yes
if I understand your head correctly
basically dispatch or send an event by
making this metric hole to the state
oportunidad yep from the underside right
so how do you avoid a stack good
question the main reason so we mainly
require in the pattern that things have
to be insert tail call position for
those languages actually have tail call
optimization so in that case the the
problem there is no problem ultimately
of doing so for those languages which do
a second such as Java at the very moment
the second property of that proxy system
is to basically allow you to break out
of this of each stack as you go along so
when you call a method it stores the
event and then the method exits then it
can then execute the next event on the
other side and so on making sure that
you never grow the stack to an arbitrary
depth you need to do that at the moment
you do because Java does not but other
language but other languages do which is
why we still call this you know a
general pattern in that sense okay any
other questions yes I know you carefully
carefully give the disclaimer that
you're looking at solutions separately
we so basically when I asked if you have
any thoughts about combining this
pattern with the extensibility
yes I have in the the problem that we we
come across here is a sort of covariance
contravariance problem so in the state
does estate design pattern all events
are going one direction meaning that
it's easy for us to add new operations
because we have you know and all those
will still be valid but if we
have this sort of this bi-directional
message flow then if we extend one way
then we have to sort of then the other
direction becomes problematic because
then when you're going to new states
that maybe not accept types of the meal
going the other direction the standard
you know same thing as like return
values and in arguments in a function so
in that kind of case it becomes harder
to have extensibility doesn't mean that
we don't want something like that and
that we can't get something like that
which is sort of change how we look at
it and I haven't I haven't come up with
a full idea of how to do that yet okay
any other questions okay so I want talk
briefly about the case study we did for
this particular project so some of you
may be familiar with the games letters
of catan now there's an existing
implementation of settlers of catan for
java called j settlers now the game's
letters of catan is a fairly complicated
game where there's a lot of exchanges of
control between the player the game
other players and so on and this
existing project uses an use an ad hoc
message passing system between the
server and the clients that look
something like this and this is
necessary because again with a state
design pattern you know we could only
sort of capture the protocol going in
one direction it says this has to go
both directions a servant that they'd
have to have two different sides on
reducing so they decided to go with the
standard manual event dispatch do it to
execute this anyway so the goal of this
project was to enforce a well-defined
interactive protocol between each of the
clients of this game and the server
using our dialogue pattern we did this
because the seizure control could be
hopefully done more easily um we could
add this and we want to demonstrate the
scalability of this to say that not only
can this sort of model work for a simple
project for simple protocols with
something that's much more general in
the first place as well yes
two were so there were these two players
and there are two players but the idea
is that the dialogue pattern it
determines how much are passing back and
forth between between two entities so
kind of if we had each client and the
player has one of these protocols
between them so we don't necessarily say
how all the players interact with each
other through the server but we say at
least the server and the client have to
follow this particular logic yes just
you say you mentioned in that main
reason you had moved them in question is
because you don't want to blow yes so
what's the program looking on the client
mainly because you know the block is
from the point of view that it sends an
event to the server and is waiting
around for the server to respond right
especially the very sore systems as a
friend but from classic view is a dream
world well it's me it's not from the
perspective of cost it's mainly from the
perspective of you know of user
experience because if you're sending an
event let's say that you send an event
and wait the server has to do something
expensive to figure out what's next like
for example polling all the other
players to figure out what's the oh what
other people want to do in order to
respond to this well if the client is
blocking that's all there is then you
know it can't you know anything like
button clicks other stuff like that
won't be able to respond be able to
react that kind of thing so in order to
be able to sort of have this or general
pattern we wanted to avoid blocking that
make sense okay so the result of this so
there's there's two aspects to this to
our result which is the protocol and the
implementation so the protocol these are
developed sort of in turn iteratively
but i'll talk about you sort of
independently for right now the protocol
is shown below sorry if it's a little
too small to read but just to show that
it actually does exist and work
appropriately we have 30 states in six
different sub protocols these sort of
fragments of interactive logic and the
big thing to take away from this is that
we had first up we had 64 different
event types which was actually more than
that of the original but the idea was
that we only have we had a much smaller
number of them than you have to handle
any individual state we had five events
at max for any one state and on average
we had just about to in general which
meant that the amount of implantation we
needed
each at each different state was much
smaller because we only had handle a few
different operations at that point in
time I which technique this is the
dialogue pattern yeah so we're just so
we're going through this sorry I didn't
establish that yeah yeah this is using
the dialogue pattern here so this is the
protocol we designed for this and that's
what the implementation again according
to the pattern the stated control were
fairly trivial to handle and the this in
rated pattern we did we served yes we
took a look at the existing protocol we
tried to model it using our protocol
implement it and then we sort of back
and then when we found sort of a way of
either simplifying or needed a change
that need to be happy to the protocol we
changed the protocol in order to
accommodate this and the idea is that as
we did this the whole the static type
system provide us a lot of help about
knowing what we needed to change next so
by adding kind of a new method new
events to something we would then be
told oh this that and the other classes
throughout your code need to add this
method too because it doesn't implement
at the moment and so we could you this
was a great help and actually developing
this thing from this developing this
thing and finally this idea of sub
protocol this code reuse that was
provided by sub sub protocols was
convenient at several steps within here
okay so these are my three a general
approaches now I'm going to briefly talk
about the related work and get to a
little bit of future work and finally
conclude so in terms of problem of
inversion of control there are a number
of different there are a number of
different techniques that already have
been developed most of these have to
deal with ways of saving or pausing
current execution to be either restored
or resumed at some point in the future
you know you have co routines or sort of
the general way of having multiple
methods yield control back to each other
as you see which steel uterus or related
envy of capturing execution inside of
closures in order to be resumed at a
future time have it using cooperator
multi tasking order switch between
different things using a schedule to
switch between them and so on responder
j the main project they dealt with the
virtual control i leverage some of these
techniques but in addition added this
idea that this sort of compatibility
between the operated model and
everything else providing for instance
this idea of you know a way of comparing
when these things inside of an object
for easy execution as well
having the ability to use these methods
and use object-oriented techniques such
as inheritance and it said to be able to
override these methods as well yes
routines this is good question this is
just it this is an example this was this
is the third edition of the art of
computer programming which of course
just ends up being done in 97 so there's
an earlier version of this thing in
there too so this is the reference it
happens to be in my dissertation so they
are older they like sad of activities
yeah absolutely I think his was at 77
there's earlier ones thinking that the
late 60s or something like that so I
this is this is just again this is an
example of a reference yes yes yes the
way it actually works it does requires a
separate execution context but that's
encapsulated within an object in order
to sort of be kept you know it's sort of
its own little world so that doesn't you
know it interacts minimally with
everything else letting you still have
this object model that it uses does that
mean that you're taking stated with us
that
at the moment it means I have multiple
stacks the movie the trial flotation i
have actually uses is a prototype so
uses a threads in order to implement
sort of these other lines there's no
reason that you have to use that though
you can certainly have a compilation
strategy which transforms it into just
being sort of the more standard state
design pattern style code of java
threads yes another kind of
that is correct yes I know maybe I
should wait and you have more I have two
more slides related work that's Alan see
ok next we have sort of the question of
extensibility overall and the most
important problem they demote the most
related work for that is the expression
problem which talks which is the
discusses the problem of adding new
operations to an interface while
simultaneously extending from that same
interface there are a number of
solutions for this include in all sorts
of languages including summons plane
Scala and Java the main thing we provide
with the extensible state designed the
extensible state design a machine
pattern I'm sorry is the the ability to
since we're talking about this
interactive world talking about states
we're actually able to use that
domain-specific knowledge to simplify
the existing techniques so r XR
implementation technique is actually
simpler than some of these other ones
and so we can you know it does require
so much work to actually implement
finally do we have for the whole idea
the dialogue pattern and symmetric and
and this idea symmetric control we have
some related work so first off we of
course have sing sharp and channel their
multiple language feat languages and
language feeders have been added in
order to handle this kind of exchange of
control such as a sink sharp and channel
contracts as well as the atf session
types so both of these of course require
fundamental changes to the language in
order than that fundamental but they
need to change the language or to be
able to run whereas a dialogue pattern
or is a simple pattern on top of the
existing language in addition I these do
not have this idea of sub protocols as
well to be lied for this kind of code
reuse finally we have this idea of
static analysis which are tools in order
to sort of detect the flow of states
throughout the states of different
values throughout your throughout an
approaching program so we have alton
view which modify the state the the type
system of a language or to sort of keep
track of these type properties as well
as slam and blast which use sort of a
more whole program analysis in order to
sort of text these things these tools
specifically are designed to execute on
top of you to be used on existing code
with mental changes whereas our stuff is
designed primarily to create new code in
and also they VM and once again the
whole doesn't require do you doesn't
require seem to be any kind of real
swell that's fine sorry um anyway so now
we have so now for my future work so the
first problem that I saw here with the
dialogue pattern approach is the fact
that we can't deal with asynchronous
protocols that is you know right now in
a particular state either one side or
the other of a protocol has to be the
next one to send a message whether
plenty of times not even deal with
concurrency specifically just in terms
of just general use we're both entities
have a valid message to be sent you know
at the same state and so in that kind of
case we want to be able to adapt our
adapt this mechanism to handle those
kinds of asynchronous protocols on top
of that you know given that then we
might want to actually talk about the
true concurrent components which sort of
follows more the actor method but see if
we can find a way to sort of integrate
so what we've done with that as simply
as possible of course all that together
sort of brings up the question of what
you know given some of these techniques
and ideas what new languages for
interactive software can we come up with
in order to be leveraged stuff like you
know the sub protocol to I ideas that we
have in there so yeah and finally uh and
furthermore if this whole concept are
creating new ideas or getting more into
the interest in the idea of rapid
language prototyping overall finally I'm
still interested in sort of my older
work which is the idea of making user to
user defined type systems for you know
correctness with an existing program so
people can define their own type systems
as it need need to for various for their
own defined you know semantics and
guarantees huh yes excuse me so in
conclusion I believe interactive
software is an important class of
software which is made more difficult to
read write maintained by some of the
problems in the best practice solutions
and within this talk we provided
solutions for three important problems a
version of control lack of modularity
asymmetric control all of which try to
maintain as much compatibility as
possible with existing mainstream
languages and that's it are there any
questions yeah
think you've done quite a good job and
javanne oh but in your own related work
section all of the systems you referred
to a research systems I'm just wondering
if you've had access to c sharp and in
particular to the features there such as
delegates yield statements and um I'm
familiar with familiar with C sharp I
have not actually tried out these ideas
with C sharp my main approach here is
that most of stuff i'm using in java is
is similar enough in c-sharp be able to
use the same techniques it so becomes
sort of more general thing overall while
there might be ways of leveraging those
particular features in c-sharp to do
things possibly better at least these
techniques as I've written them up here
will work is that at your question
yeah I think those ones all chicolini
advanced so they'd be with leukemia yes
there that you probably could leverage
will more yet more advanced particular
language features in order to you know
get some get these things done in a
better way but this one will should work
over hopefully a larger scope of
languages as it stands okay yes maybe a
good rough for them and I think Corey's
are at least a generation older the idea
human dinner right yes I I agree it
again like I said before there's a
there's early related work which that
was sort of mean that is certainly a
related workers can trace back farther
but again like I said I upon looking it
up it's I think some around late 60s I
can't remember exactly who where the
idea was sort of first brought up yes so
i got this impression so i'm very
interested in interactive software
systems and you've tied with three
really interesting problems in that
space and we come up with interesting
solutions but left with compression that
they don't play well together and so I'm
trying to decide all right so which ones
should i should i tackle first how do i
make a decision about which in my
solution space it's given one I have to
rule out the others right there are
aspects of each which are it's sort of
like you can divide each one of
different aspects the different aspects
that are compatible one another but it's
not like a one is completely sort of you
can't take one please set one on top of
the other one so these different my
thought mainly is again like with stuff
like the desires that we have your
something techniques might still be
capla like with the accessible state
machine pattern certainly do want to do
something like that with a dialogue
pattern but you just can't do it in the
exact same way there might be sort of
ways the elements of that pattern you
could leverage it might require
something more than just a pattern on
top of the language but the ideas there
are still somewhat saying so they aren't
they aren't entirely able to be set on
top of one another but I think there's
still some kind of way that the sum of
the parts of the contents can be can
have some interplay unified I wish I
were by no no yes the when you start
talking with the event loop again the
bishop said you want to avoid blocking
yes so quite hard well sort of two
questions why not just put the coat you
know excuse me on supper thread so
you're not blocking the event loop and
the hook site is your solution looks a
lot like actors yes right you know and
we receive a message you do pattern
matching
chocolate shake and write and execute
some quotes so how was it is it
different yes so I answered them again
in sequence first I'd be repeating these
questions or no okay um so first off
we're dealing with threads you know
threads certainly are a solution but
they also interested in the process they
also potentially add some introduce some
problems first off you have you know the
standard concurrency problems such as
deadlock race conditions that kind of
thing which may come up depending on how
you actually implemented but even on top
of that the threads themselves are try
are all sort of run to buy a scheduler
which of course determines which thread
to run at which particular time so even
if you are correctly locking to avoid
all these various problems you have the
problem of a indeterminate of non
deterministic execution of your program
which would become more of a problem
when you start dealing with you know
trying to debug your solution or attract
some complicated thing farther down your
program just understand how it actually
will ultimately work in all conditions
the responder J ensures you know among
others that every sort of switch of
control from one thing to another is at
a very well defined time in a
particularly well defined order so you
don't have unless you introduce
concurrency on your own via other
threads there's no or your synchronous
queues or something like that then
you're not then you won't actually come
across these kind of non deterministic
problems so that's that as for the
second question again artha we're not
saying that our original thing is
necessarily the idea of like pausing and
resuming execution as you would and
actors among other things the key thing
is sort of the idea of again these two
sort of problems one thing I didn't
wasn't able to describe in full detail
but the ability to define these
responders as part of an existing object
that's define part of that object
interface as being the way of
interacting with this thing and on top
of that the idea of using standard
object-oriented techniques such as
inheritance in order to modify
responding code so every if I want to
have
responding method you call something
else that does fuzz did all the
intermediate frames have to be
responding no no does not here so the
rule of thumb is that you can only call
it one responding method from another
responding method but anything else you
can generally call from any
non-responding thing you can call from
within a responding method so it's
actual threat with a call for the
implementation I you have to you have to
maintain a call stack true but there you
don't really did there are techniques
besides threads in order to do so like I
didn't describe further in the enters
the related work limit continuations for
example are a way of standardly
capturing multiple levels of stack frame
in a way that doesn't require that's
termina singh doesn't require any kind
of threads as well do that throughout
your focus right anything that might get
all right but in this case rasili with
responder J you also have the issue that
since you know that all the responding
Lodge is going to be captured within
this one object your your scope is
someone limited so you don't actually
have to worry about the entire us the
program only the responding methods in
one particular object falls and the
things that calls for the most part do
that stuff is not going to actually I
that stuff cannot actually have to vent
loops in it only events would only
appear inside of this responding code
and that's sort of the key observation
so in the calls back to you I you call
you call so it calls back to you as a
responding that it's a good call
responding method that calls back to
another respond the same responding
method or something like that but you
can't actually have something that has
an event loop internally otherwise you
have to do exactly what you're talking
about which is have sort of this story
this positive execution go out to the
rest of the entire rest of the system in
this way we sort of limit the scope and
you know it's a design decision but I
think it's the right one for this
particular case but it essentially rules
not using
in this case I suppose it does yes so
any other questions yes so two problems
that come up like the staple systems are
parts where you have rather independent
components so like this state will
change very different in this state and
how are they attract like that mm-hmm
the other one is often you go you'll
you'll be in a state and then someone
will do something and they'll change a
few things or it's like that makes it so
something acts differently but most
everything else that's the same right
and I don't see how either gets
addressed by the system so the thought
mean this is actually what I've thought
about a little bit so with the dialog
pattern for instance the thought is
you'd basically have it I have an actual
idea dad for the current-voltage I'm not
sure if I could do this completely but
the idea is you kind of have multiple
state machines being run within the same
thing each would have their own certain
protocols by sending an event one of
them you're not necessarily modifying
the behavior of another one so they
could be in end of sort of semi
independent states so in that kind of
case in the pattern as it stands you
sort of implement a serve its own sort
of entity within this thing where you
know the thing that's trying to call
into the the trying to send events to
one of these objects is sending them
it's setting imma two different along
two different channels own way or
another implementing each of those
appropriately now as for like trying to
sync them up like partially as in like
you know if they're you know the same if
they're an independent most the time but
like if this one particular one they
have to be in the same one I have no
particular way in this pattern of sort
of enforcing that kind of situation we
we cut our level as being as just
between the protocol between two
different components so the rest of you
turned up didn't land on your own
okay any other questions yes just to get
this mean the context of design patterns
your dialogue patent we would fit in
with a mediator and the observer and so
on patterns that passing right the so
we're actually using kind of a form of
mediator pattern with a sort of picture
of service this client server
architecture but it kind of means the
meteor Pater sort of sitting on top of
everything else so we have each of those
clients dealing with the server which
kind of X's the mediator for its
interaction which then sends other which
talks the other components or do not
interact with them so instead of
becoming kind of like it becomes it can
be used as kind of a component of these
other patterns as in whereas before we'd
have sure this interview of major
pattern have an interface where you send
a function to and then it calls other
other methods on other objects to be
able to handle it you deal with this
dialogue pattern to communicate with the
mediator to deal with it that way
similar the observer the observers a
little bit more simple that's basically
almost the time what the observer
pattern is just simply a I want to be
notified when X happens and that is
normally independent that isn't actually
doesn't ever reverse control is just
sort of like I'm not going to change
anything I'm just going to sit here and
watch what happens it probably the
dialogue pattern probably would not come
up as easily but maybe there's scenario
where it could but I can't think of one
right now okay you're welcome any other
questions